[Applause]
[Music]
why is it we don't believe in
ourselves why is it that as soon as
things get tough in our lives we start
doubting ourselves we start thinking
that we may not make it through
stressing
worrying imagining things that may go
wrong in the
future I'll tell you the human mind is
powerful but it can also be
destructive it can be your greatest
friend or your worst
enemy the person you see reflecting in
the mirror will always provide you your
greatest challenges in
[Music]
life take control of your life control
of your
mind there will always be doubs but if
you stay true to yourself and believe
then one day will be your
[Music]
moment conquer
yourself and you can conquer anything in
this
world yes easy to be positive when
everything is going your way but are you
going to be one of the very few who
stand up when things are tough when
everything is going against
you that's when you must show
yourself that's when your character will
shine through that's when your story
will be
born your story of success you ain't
building no story if you give up the
world is full of people who gave up the
world needs hope the world needs you to
stand up to fight through your
challenging moment to shine through the
darkness to
love through
the believe in
yourself there was nothing more
important stay hungry hungry for Success
hungry for more most people are loaded
with ordinary they are full of arage
having appetite for
Extraordinary
remember anything is possible if you
believe keep your dreams
alive understand that in order for you
to have anything of Great Value you must
suffer and
endure suffer the setb endure the pain
and rise to to Greatness through your
courage through your perseverance and
tick one day this world will tap you on
the shoulder and whistle it's your time
to sh you can have be and do anything
you just got to
believe you are destined for
[Music]
success